reggie miller the hall of famer will be
on the call western conference finals
between the nuggets and the lakers tips
off friday night at 9 eastern on tnt
reggie joining us from his crib uh you
got to throw away all your notes there
for the western conference finals wait a
minute
it's not the lakers clippers wait a
minute did something
happen what happened last night
i think the clippers are saying the same
thing what did happen last night
look uh before we get into the clippers
bashing which it's been plentiful
because of their performance in this
series really in the restart
let's give a lot of credit to michael
malone and the denver nuggets
they were the better team they didn't
now people are gonna be like what are
you talking about the better team no
the clippers had the better assortment
of talent
you had a two-time finals mvp in kauai
leonard uh lou williams a three-time
six-man
year winner uh montrez harold won it
this year
and let's not forget last year paul
george finished third people
third in nvp voting so they had the
better collection of
individual talent the better team
was michael malone and the denver
nuggets
and jokic was the best player
in this series over those four guys i
just mentioned for the clippers
so let's give them a lot of love now
let's get to the clippers
because i'm more upset
with the post game in the comments than
the actual series okay
now all of a sudden there was division
we weren't unified
we weren't together where was all this
before why does everything need to come
out
after you're exiting the bubble and then
right paul george had this to say
this is what got to me it's obvious
pressure you know to
to live up to the title expectations but
as a player i mean
you want that like you know you you want
that um again it's first time i've i've
been in that situation where we're
expected to win
but you know it is what it is um it's
it's
it's no cop-out um
fact of the matter is we didn't live up
to that expectation
uh but i think internally we we've
always felt
um this is not a championship or bus
year for us what do you make of that reg
come on it is a number one it is a
cop-out
and you did have expectations while
you're in indiana
when you were the number when you were
batman
right everywhere else you've been okc
here in the clippers
you've been robbing which suits him
probably better
when you were batman in indiana
and you were going toe-to-toe with
lebron james and then mommy heat
there were expectations for you to win
and you could have won
that series and you should have won you
did capture home court advantage
versus the heat now they came into
indiana and won and recaptured it
but there were expectations for you to
win in indiana
so for you to say and sit back and say
uh
we need to be together longer for us to
win a championship
come on man it's a cop out the better
team one
which was the denver nuggets and your
play
you know people ask well who's the blame
there's a lot of blame to go around
but if you're asking me which i'm sure
you are theodore
paul george doc rivers and then probably
kawhi leonard
all three of those guys got to take the
brunt mantras harold and lou williams
were absolutely terrible
this whole restart now i know they
weren't together the whole time
mantra spent time away because of the
passing of his grandmother
we all know about you know lou will and
magic city and all that
those are excuses you still did not
perform
once you got back in the bubble because
those two guys were terrible off the
bench and i thought those were going to
be the two guys
that were carr were going to carry them
especially when paul
george and kawhi had off nights but when
all four were terrible
they had zero shot who do you think the
lakers
wanted to face the clippers and here's
the thing about they
wanted to face the clippers yes because
the clippers
all their whole campaign this season
was dissing their crosstown rivals
it was all about the lakers it was all
about diminishing
their accomplishments there was a new
sheriff in town
so the clippers main focus and they
almost got away with it theodore
they almost got away with it by getting
to the conference finals and facing them
was to diss the la lakers
and make them uh patrick beverly all
them saying
lebron who and we're the better team
there's a new sheriff in town
and they almost got away with it they
were up 3-1
one more game and they would have got
their wish and i
i think i texted you i would have been
surprised
i wouldn't have been surprised if they
would got to the conference finals
because they only wanted to play the
lakers and beat lebron
and the lakers to show everyone here in
la
that there's a new sheriff in town but
they probably would have went on and
lost
the nba finals because their whole focus
was derided on one team
and that's the lakers and the lakers
want to be like okay bring it on
lebron was back there waiting on him we
did our part
all right we're waiting okay come on
let's go
let's get this going and then they come
out and they disappoint like that
so whatever is coming to clippers way
they deserve
i'm upset because on this show numerous
of times you have asked me
who was the better team who did i expect
winning
the west and every time what did i tell
you
the cliffhangers clippers had kawhi paul
george better wing defenders better
defense
they've had a championship coach in doc
rivers
and they laid an egg on national
tv shooting shots on the side of the
backboard
are you kidding me how are you kidding
me that's your best effort in a game
seven
how safe is doc rivers how safe should
he be
here's the question who is out there
that would be better than doc
to come in well now i don't know he's
been down this road before
being up 3-1 i believe it's happened two
previous times
in his coaching stint yeah that he's
lost a 3-1 lead
but i don't know who could come in and
replace him and be
better but i want to know
how attached are kawhi and paul george
to doc rivers because they become free
agents after next season they can opt
out
i don't know if he's on the hot seat uh
probably should be on a warm seat
ty lue ty lue might be the guy that you
could bring in there
um and keep because you got to keep
those guys if you don't keep those two
guys
you have mortgaged your future for this
year and next year to try to win a
championship and that's what they did
they went all in and traded all their
draft picks
shea gilges alexander they got rid of
him as well
you know they got to keep those two guys
and resign them
which is why paul george comments are
idiotic
that it's going to take time for us to
build a championship team
no no no no we built this team
to win this year today right now
not that you know we've got to you know
go camping together
get around the campfire and seeing some
kumbaya
and bring up you know that chemistry no
we were
built to win this year
so don't be coming to me that now all of
a sudden we're having
chemistry problems and we need to work
on ourselves come on man give me a break
stop it
explain joe kitch's greatness because
when you watch
like we had a writer uh on last hour
from the only times dan white and he
said it's you know it's like a beautiful
glacier
moving like he he moves slow
but he always seems to accomplish what
he's setting out to do it feels like
right and it's almost a perfect storm
with him because
at times he can be too unselfish
you know you would want him to be a
little bit more aggressive here's the
thing
he's always wanting to make the correct
play
he's very reminiscent and people are
going to be like you're crazy
he's like magic magic wanted to feed
everyone come just run hard
i'll i'll get you the basketball his
offense came a little bit later in terms
of
being aggressive magic jokic
wants to feed all these guys and he
wants to make sure
his guys are in the best light in the
best situation
and there's times where you want him to
be more aggressive but
what makes him fabulous is and i think
uh
jeff van gundy was was dead on he can't
see the double team coming
because at seven foot he's too skilled
of a passer
and there's only one other guy that i've
ever seen make a pass that he did last
night
the over the head and i saw the numerous
occasions in pickup games
was magic johnson i mean eyes in the
back of your head
there's no one else i've ever seen do
that pass
and it was all eye contact he knew
exactly where jamal murray was going
and it was a pinpoint pass so we sleep
on his greatness i say that i said this
five times on the air when we were
covering those series
he is the most skilled offensive big man
in the game today and i don't think it's
even close okay but how did the lakers
match up with denver
i still like look this is the lakers now
and i guarantee probably what's going to
happen and we solve this from the lakers
in the first round
um versus portland in the first round in
the second round versus houston
they'll probably lay an egg in that
first game and lose and everyone's going
to go all crazy oh my god what's wrong
with the lakers and they reeled off four
straight games
they've been off a while i'm sure
they're probably a little bit complacent
because
they were envisioning you know facing
the clippers
they'll probably be a letdown in game
one
i have the lakers
i mean five would be very disrespectful
to denver after what they've done in
back to back being down three ones and
coming back and winning
so i'll say six to be respectful to the
denver nuggets
can you explain and we're talking to
reggie miller reggie will be on the call
friday night the game one western
conference finals nuggets lakers
explain to me kyle kuzma because he's an
enigma
i don't know from game to game quarter
to quarter half to half
is he a a great player potentially a
great player or just
potentially a good player potentially a
good player okay
on potentially a great
hall of fame type team with anthony
davis and lebron james
we call those people x factors right
theodore
when he's on this lakers
team goes to a different level because
they have that third level score
he has size at 6 10 can run the floor
and when he wants to play defense
he's not bad but to me if rondo
continues to play like he's playing it's
going to be lights out
we didn't see this at the restart for
the lakers and
in those first couple uh rounds
especially in the first round
rondo as another layer because he's a
championship point guard
and it takes the ball away from lebron
and allows him
to roam free and when he catches the
pass and it's a dribble or two and he's
at the rim
he's a different type of playmaker as
opposed to always being
the guy that has to facilitate rondo
adds a different layer to the lakers
which if he continues to play like this
and make his three-point shot
it's lights out yeah that's why i don't
want to hear the excuses that the
clippers have of chemistry because the
lakers
they turned over their roster to bring
in anthony davis
uh rondo didn't start he got hurt avery
bradley opted out
and you got some g-league guys that are
out there contributing on this team
and i haven't heard any chemistry issues
with the lakers so i don't
know oh by the way um a first-time coach
you know first year coach in frank vogel
so i don't want to hear chemistry
problems and
you know secretly things are i don't
want to hear all that people have found
a way to make things work
do you want to jump on my uh miami heat
bandwagon
what do you mean you and i are out we're
the same are you in first place
are you in first class yes i'm in first
class with you and in fact i might be
the pilot no i'm the one i might be the
buyer
i am the pilot i am the pilot of the
miami heat
i i love watching them play reg out of
all the nba teams in the bubble
i loved phoenix and i loved watching
miami and
they always seem like they're never out
of the game you know they were down
double
digits in game one last night versus
boston but they just
chip away because number one toughness
defense which was on full display on
that last play by tatum
in the block by bam bam wow but they
have shot makers
jimmy butler was kind of quiet you know
through four quarters and he erupts
they've got rookies off the bench like
hero duncan's a young player who can
stretch the floor with shooting gorham
dragon
since being inserted into the starting
lineup in these playoffs
i mean let's not forget he's an all-star
player
so eric spoelstra knows exactly what
buttons to put
to push i believe that series is going
to go seven that's going to go back and
forth yeah probably so
um kemba walker kemba walker
liability both ends yeah well you know
as good as he is offensively you know
giving up that size
to those guys they always feel that they
have a mismatch
and one thing eric sports is going to do
and this is why he's a championship
coach
he understands matchups and he knows how
to exploit them
and this goes back to who runs the miami
heat and that's pat riley because that's
why
pat riley is a hall of fame coach with
the lakers and the knicks
in miami he understands uh how to
exploit a mismatch
and that's what we're going to see
throughout this series paulie was it
four years ago
three years ago i talked about bam
adebayo he was going to be a future
all-star
yeah fall 2017. that's what i thought
wait a minute
really yeah yeah well in today's game
that's how the sinners have to look yeah
look at jokic even though he's
much taller than bam your center has to
be able to stretch the floor
and face the basket and shoot got to be
a skilled passer which bam and yokitjar
rebound which both dude what was it 22
23 rebounds last night for yokids and a
triple double
and you got to be able to defend that's
one thing that bam has
over yokage but he's improving paulie do
you remember when
duncan robinson was playing division
three basketball and i said iam's
college
yeah and i i said i think i've seen one
of the great shooters
in in the world 2015 2015.
and i i can go back uh remember tyler
hero uh his
uh sophomore year in high school and i
said that dude can play man
you were calling him harrow back then
yeah i know i thought i thought he was
uh
from uh from europe i thought it was
harold not
hero harrow tyler harrow
well have fun on friday night there reg
thank you i mean look i'm sure
a lot of people are disappointed
especially you know
the la fan base they wanted to see the
matchup that
everyone's been talking about all year
especially with kawhi and paul george
you know in the clippers but
don't go to sleep on denver nuggets they
are a fun young team to watch they're
well coached with michael malone
and if they can get something out of
gary harris jeremy grant
monte morris those others and still get
big performances from jamal murray and
jokic
this could be a fun series now you know
who else is
happy that the denver nuggets are in the
finals
javale mcgee and dwight howard because
they were
relegated to the bench in that houston
series now that you've got
mason plumley and jokic two bigs for
denver
that puts dwight howard and javel mcgee
back in play
paul remember back uh was it late 90s
when lebron was
in high school sophomore yeah sophomore
and i said you know he could be in the
nfl as a wide receiver
but i think he's going to be one of the
great basketball players of all time
was that what year was that 99.99 yeah
we got it on tape reg it's all well i
hear you talking i don't hear the tape
going
well i just we're trying to recall espn
kept all the tape
you know when i left espn they kept all
that good stuff like that okay
all right okay all right thank you
wrench
you're the best theodore dance i love
y'all with
bubble time
reggie aloysius miller jr iii